this is a production of Cornell
University
so uh my name is Chris smart and I am a
plant pathologist I study diseases of
plants my lab focuses on diseases of
vegetables but we have also gotten into
diseases of hemp and today I am here
with my student Patrick McMullen and um
so and the other thing I want to point
out again is that uh Patrick made a
really nice handout on root rot issues
in hemp and so if you scan the QR code
that's on the um on the agenda you'll
pull that up and that so all of the
handouts from today's field day will be
up online at the Cornell hemp website
and you'll be able to find them there so
Patrick
thank you Chris all right good morning
everyone so I'm a PhD student here
working in Chris's lab and I've been
working with root rot pathogens of hemp
um and I've been working with some root
rot uh pathogens soil-borne pathogens of
hemp most recently with pythium I'm sure
a lot of you have dealt with pythium in
seedlings and damping off issues in
greenhouse and outdoor production so
pythium is an oh my seat pathogen
that causes damping off and early
seedling death
the swimming oh spores I really like the
water and damp soils and you'll
experience this disease a lot more in
those cool wet climates so in this
experiment I'm running now
we have these two Flats of seedlings
these are two week old seedlings the one
that Ali over here is holding
are just healthy chewy gold seedlings
um Chris is over here
they're dead there's nothing
so uh can you put it over here Chris
yeah can you point it for me yep so take
a look as they bring these Flats around
and just look at the extreme difference
there of what fit the M candy seats my
current research interest here is
testing control strategies of lithium we
all know that there's very few labeled
products for hemp right now and all
that's currently in the research process
and to see what's efficacious and what
is approved
um so here I tested some difference I
had two Copper products and a phosphate
product and as you can see in Chris's
flat none of that seemed to be effective
um but of course we're still in the
process of testing more seed treatments
to help prevent these damping off issues
they're very photogenic
[Laughter]
ulation
yep so to do this I planted these are
just styrofoam Flats with 128 cell flat
all one seed lot
um and they were direct seeded into
potting soil
and then these trays were placed in a
tub of water and just allowed to float
on top tobacco is often started in a
similar method to this so then what I
did in the inoculated group was I had
Petri plates of lithium growing and we
scraped off the spores from those plates
and dumped that inoculum into the water
so this Forest could the swimming Zoe
spores could enter the roots in the soil
seedlings as they're germinating and you
can see that in this tray here there is
practically no root growth coming out
the bottom and then in alleys over here
there's all of those healthy white roots
um so other signs of pythium that you'll
often see if you do have plants that
emerge more are kind of a Browning of
the stem as it does stamp off
um and brown roots are also quite common
and this is a commonly observed disease
in greenhouses and hydroponic production
early anywhere where there's a lot of
water and it can easily be transmitted
if there's any kind of splashing of that
contaminated material so right now we
don't really have good chemical control
strategies but of course you could
employ some good cultural practices good
sanitation methods between
your cropping seasons and cycles and
starting with clean planting material
so those are kind of the best uh
the best information I could give you
for epithium right now I'm also
interested in a fusarium which is
another soil-borne pathogen which causes
some similar disease symptoms you'll
often see wilting and yellowing on
larger plants and eventual plant
collapse in depth on young seedlings you
can see damping off similar to what we
saw here with lithium
and we're testing some of the same
control strategies for those right now
as well if you scan your QR codes on
those on your scheduled there's a more
detailed fact sheet about fusarium and
its life cycle but similar to 50m it
also likes those cool wet soils
and it it's really an environmental
fungus in the soil that persists for a
long time so it's important to have
healthy seedlings established backhand
withstand the soil worm pathogens and
really encourage early brooding
um and since these are all soil worn
pathogens our lab is also interested in
the soil of health and microbial
communities surrounding the roots so I'm
currently involved in a soil microbiome
study where we're analyzing and sending
off samples of root cores that are
around the growing
hemp plants in the field to analyze what
microbes are present throughout the
growing season both have transplant and
then as we progress closer to harvest so
our interest in what the microbial
composition is what kind of bacteria and
fungi are in that area and how this
changes over the season and how we can
use this information to better inform
our practices about growing strategies
and controls of disease and diseases
and Chris do you have more to add
I always have more
um I will say that uh if you see damping
off in your Greenhouse or in your field
we would actually be happy to get
samples we want to know which is the um
species so pythium as Patrick said Is a
water mole that loves water but you know
it here in New York or or in the
Northeast what are we dealing with the
most because if we're going to be
looking at seed treatments or cultivars
that may have some resistance we want to
be using the pathogen that you guys are
dealing with most frequently and so
anything you can get to us that that
will go right into our screen
um just to see oh is it more aggressive
is it less aggressive what's most common
that we see or is it just a total mixed
bag depending on what fusarium or
pythium you may have on your farm I'll
also say that
soil-borne diseases generally are worse
in heavy soils here in Geneva they call
our soil loam I think they're using that
word remarkably generously for the soils
that we have
um and and you know we we do see a lot
of puddling a lot of we see some root
rot and and just it's not a well-drained
soil anything you can do to increase the
drainage as Patrick said will certainly
enhance the health of the plant and
reduce the possibilities of root rot and
then the other thing I was talking to a
few people beforehand is that hemp is
also just very susceptible to to flood
damage so sometimes plants will look
like this and it's they simply have
drowned they're not they're not very
good at holding up in standing water so
again anything you can do to enhance the
drainage of your soil will certainly
will certainly help and the final thing
that I always say when I'm at extension
meetings is that while Patrick as well
he should be is very pleased with this
experiment and we're very we smile a lot
about disease plants this is a research
experiment
um you know we we are we are killing
plants in our research Labs so that we
can learn more about what's happening on
the farms in New York
um we hope that you never see anything
like this but if you do let us know
because we want to make sure that we're
helping everyone that has
problems so and this afternoon uh we'll
be talking about powdery mildews which
is also another issue here in New York
and that will feature alley so questions
yes
what are you doing genetically are you
doing any plant breeding for pathogen
resistance bulky soil and for
controlling weeds like they have Roundup
Ready soybeans and such so the question
the question is about breathing
strategies right now are we breeding for
resistance to diseases
um for userium and pythium not currently
we don't know if there's genetic
resistance that's further research
projects that could take place but we
just don't have that information
currently available in other pathogens
like powdery mildew which if you come to
the afternoon sessions uh there are
breeding programs taking place here for
a powdery mildew resistant hemp so it's
currently ongoing work and there's some
there's optimistic results with some of
that what about weeds and the weeds
yeah so um for for weed control as you
were saying uh glyphosate resistant
plants
um we have uh Faith hat who is here
somewhere has been working on hemp
transformation and uh has both uh tissue
culture and transformation up and
running we we currently do not have any
plans to put ourselves
um uh herbicide resistance genes into
hemp that uh you know we're we're really
focusing on identifying cultivar you
know figuring out what the issues are
tackling uh some of the larger issues
um rather than uh focusing on the
regulatory hurdles that come with um
genetically engineered crops
at least uh you actually
um the the breeding Labs uh can talk
more about that actually I don't know
their Planet they they are looking at um
genetically engineered plants for
research purposes to control out
flowering time and other areas but to my
knowledge there's nothing that's focused
on herbicide resistance
yeah so that's
okay
um the question was do we notice these
diseases more readily in different uh
soilless media versus in the ground soil
out here or differences between
Greenhouse media we might be using
um so the true answer is we don't have
the data to support whether one's better
than the other but of course that these
pathogens really like the damp wet soil
if you heard Neil Matson presenting
earlier about the importance of drainage
in your potting potting mixes you do
want that high Airport Air porosity so
you're not saturating the plants and
making sure that they have good drainage
those are kind of the best strategies
yeah so anything with a high air for us
okay
um so this was the
the question was uh what are our our
potting mixes that we used here so this
is a peat potting mix that we just used
in our Greenhouse days here we didn't
sterilize it before often if you do
other liter soil before planting um
it's just more difficult to grow things
there are beneficial microbes that are
just always present in the environment
but we didn't add anything else to these
tea treatments it's just our peat-based
potting mixes
yeah
not Mike Horizon
[Music]
yes so Neil is talking about
environmental temperatures of the roots
so cold and wet are kind of your worst
case scenarios for growing hemp Roots
like warm temperatures and
um
well drained of course you need an
adequate amount of water but you don't
want them saturated and you certainly
don't want the root Zone
all right
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu